hello and welcome to GameSpot's the next
big game this month we feature a game
that nobody had heard of a mere eight
months ago but one that has captured the
imagination of gamers all around the
universe a game about exploration a game
about the desire to see what's over the
horizon
it's that same desire that has people
around the world desperately wanting to
know what type of game no man's sky
really is and this week will answer many
of those questions but first perhaps the
most pertinent question of all how can a
small development team based in the
South of England possibly make a game of
this scale myself and the guys from
hello games have a bit of history I met
co-founder Sean Murray at a games Expo
in London when we realized we were both
in the same County in Ireland before I
joined GameSpot I interviewed them as
they were developing their very first
game Joe danger a series that was very
successful spawning two Mobile spin-offs
and a full sequel in fact the night Joe
danger 2 was released Shaun joined us
for some beers on a GameSpot live stream
and whenever we're in the same city we
always try and cross paths so over e3 we
organized a few hours one evening to sit
down and talk to the guys from hello
games but in typical e3 fashion everyone
was running late pioneer they're running
30 minutes later over at a good friends
at Giant Bomb and the JW Marriott did I
tell you it happened this morning it's
were like 15 minutes from going live and
they're the first game when you're on
the show floor like I got a text to Alex
we caused music we're outside the South
Hall you need to be inside the West hall
and also they didn't have passes so I
had to like get wristbands off of Sarah
and like sprint and tears
can't believe you kept us waiting for
this in the audience
before hello games where did you work
what what projects is work on I actually
started out at criterion and which was
kind of pretty small at the time it was
like 15 20 people or something like that
which is like how I envisioned games to
be and then when I left it was about
like three years later and it was like
400 people or something ridiculous which
is that this massive birth
we'd been bought by yay and I didn't
know half the people on the team and
actually I enjoyed it and stuff but it
just wasn't for me forever you know the
mean and actually I was like if I stay
here I'm at that point where I can
actually picture myself being like you
know old and being here working on like
burnout or NEPA speeds for the rest of
my day
I was originally a concept artists I
worked on Warhammer Online the original
our line which never got released I
moved to sumo my work time Isis Sega
games I became an environment artist I
became the lead environmental artist on
so games like Virtua Tennis of algún and
Sega superstars tennis lots of really
colorful
Sega games didn't I couldn't I can't
give you a list of games there were
times you work for kujou I did work okay
there you go yeah and then so I didn't
have many released games until I met
Sean did you have any released games
no not so well not until not till I
won't be shown me okay how many games
did you work on the warrant released
quite a few I know there was a gameboy
game that was released okay I was very
proud of that I started out my like
pretty much first day at Criterion I was
like sat beside Ryan who had just joined
we kind of grew up together in that
studio and then I had met Dave and
worked with DES for a little bit he was
another programmer
and so there was us three coders and we
were talking about setting up and Dave
introduced us to grant and grant and
Dave used to go to school together so it
was a really tight bunch I mean we all
knew each other for years kind of thing
like it was kind of necessary because we
ended up starting our pella games in
this tiny little room you actually came
you came in there and you showed up with
the cameraman and you and that was too
many people but we were running out of
oxygen
basically Joe success meant they didn't
need to stay in that tiny room for long
as the team moved to a new studio they
expanded from four all the way up to ten
employees
expansion brings its own set of
challenges creatively so when it came to
starting a new project remarkably they
decided to split their team into there's
ten people working there and for that
for us that felt big actually that felt
like we were gone back to a big studio
like 10 isn't big but it's still some
double the size you work yeah yeah but
what fuels me is that really small team
prototyping you just love that and I
live for that it was a slightly
different for words the four founders
but with Lee had a little room in the
studio like the smallest room and we
went in there and we we genuinely just
like literally locked the door we had a
separate entrance and we didn't show the
rest of the team which sounds crazy Wow
because one it was kind of mental what
we were doing and two he gave us this
like this passion that we that we hadn't
had since Jer danger you know we were
developing that and it felt like it was
make or break the entire time and we
knew that we would have to show people
eventually and so we wanted that again
and we wanted this pressure of like the
guys are working really hard next door
and they're putting J danger on other
platforms are they're working on other
stuff working really hard and we need to
like justify what we're doing yes and we
we need them to come in and say that
it's cool or whatever so we went a bit
crazy and we actually didn't show them
until a few weeks before the VG X's no
man's sky first broke on to the
collective gaming consciousness when
Jeff Keely featured it at the Spike vgx
Awards but what you probably didn't know
it was that Sean actually tried to have
it pulled when he became worried that
people wouldn't think it was real like
Geoff Keighley seems to be some sort of
like I don't know he's got some mythical
powers and I bet he genuinely just
mailed me out of the blue and said he's
very American so he said you know if I
gave you a shot at the big time would
you take it or something like that right
and I said yes and then I told the guys
and we totally weren't prepared for it
so we just killed ourselves basically
doing it built it built had put together
video send a video out kind of got no
reaction just silence of them from Jeff
and stuff and then I got really worried
and we decided we'd show some press so
we called in some UK press and they were
just completely silent and I asked them
what they thought and they said I don't
think we should tell you right now
and they just went off we had to leave
that meeting Dave knocked on the door
and was like we have to go gone in a
taxi four of us then flew straight out
you're kidding and we actually met you
yeah that the next day well it was still
kind of the same day for us so we just
flown over and you were the first person
who saw it who said looks great and then
what I was still sorry I remember being
silent but I remember watching it and
then going wait out actually doing this
like and then what happened was I turned
and saw your faces and saw her terrified
you guys went oh [ __ ] this is real but
did you ever find out why those are the
other journalists didn't they said we
to tell you one of them kind of thought
it's just some sort of fake you know
people haven't made this and I don't
want to comment on it I guess now you
know because you've seen the public
reaction to what that must have been was
that people are thinking this is
actually this this game was trying to
fight off quite a lot I wonder if
they're able to do it yeah I guess
there's part of that right I mean we
went on the BG X's and I tried to pull
it and Jeff said I couldn't he was like
I've really fought to get you slot and
you know I'm not going back and that
that kind of thing yeah thankfully Sean
and his team suddenly had the world's
ears in the initial hype was starting to
gather the momentum of a runaway train
only an act of God could stop them now
not a white but a wet Christmas as river
levels peaked in the early hours in
parts of Surrey rescue teams were out as
record flood levels were reached and
breached across the UK more than a
hundred and yes I mean we we we were on
kind of a high actually finishing up a
Christmas it was like this is awesome
people simply reacting really well to
the game and quiz they probably the you
know the the the best thing that ever
happened to the studio kind of thing I
got a call Christmas Eve night saying
like your offices is flooding basically
and we're actually on a ground floor and
all our pcs on the ground and they were
like blowing up and exploding and things
like that what about the how did that
did that damage the game did you guys
have stuff off site back top we had
stuff off side and at the time we kind
of said don't worry guys you know we've
we haven't lost anything but in reality
you have
and you just you just don't know how
much you know and you also don't want to
say because people are just gonna go
forget about it it'll never come out it
looked crazy anyway you know so we were
just like it's fine don't worry yeah so
it did it did it did put you guys back a
while yeah absolutely and for us this e3
has been really you know for us it's
like this kinda thing like we didn't let
it stop us
the vgx has proved to be the warm-up act
that Sean took to the stage at Sony's e3
press conference giving what was once
their little four-person project even
more exposure and with it a hell of a
lot more expectation surely now even
they must be asking themselves if they
can pull it off what does it feel like
now that the game is out there and the
people are asking questions about what
this game is and to have the expectation
of other people on top of the office of
personal expectation with a project like
this I think I think's brilliant really
that's like it's what you want this what
it's like it's the best feeling really
the best feeling to have so many people
care and you know they can say what they
want really and just the fact that
they're talking about what we're making
is it's just an amazing that that fuels
you feeling down you see that when we
flooded you know it's nice to be working
on a game that people want
as a big deal but I've never experienced
this before even on like you know I'm
burn out we were you know so several
several hundred people we still weren't
on stage in one of the Vicki knows you
know that mean this is like a level of
expectation that it's really hard for
small team to deal with and yeah I mean
people want it to be every different
type of game as well it's really open to
interpretation and and we're leaving it
a little bit of making interpretations
it's definitely a tough without a purse
or in your mouth all right then let's
let's break into what exactly not
Wednesday is so you've shown off
tomorrow on GameSpot's the next big game
we unveiled the gameplay of no man's sky
we give new details about the
moment-to-moment play your role within
the universe the tools at your disposal
and the possibility of playing with
others all right I'm off to kill a
dinosaur spaceship see you then
but car was found in in a local garage
staidum they'd actually luckily they'd
pulled it up onto one of those electric
hydro whatever they called big machines
that lift the car up and then it flood
it and blew all that electrics
oh don't worry about it they're just
like yes it's up there your car was it
okay was it yes bye it was fine yeah I
could get it back a few weeks later when
they actually just you know fixed
everything got it back
he's still driving it today no it's it's
died of its own accord now okay but we
won't talk about that I like it Oh like
final destination of cars survived and
then it just it was meant to die